- [Kelly] Did you enjoy
doing "Good Burger 2"?
- [Kenan] I loved it.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- [Kenan] Oh my gosh.
Shout out to Kel Mitchell.
- [Kelly] Kind of cool to like...
Yeah, he was here.
So wait, doing it like years later.
That's so awesome.
- [Kenan] It's amazing.
I mean, a 26 year gap is just
like really hard to imagine.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Yes.
- [Kenan] But you know,
we both look very young still,
so that's good.
(Kelly and audience laughs)
And people seem to enjoy the movie,
so like we couldn't be prouder.
Like it was a great response
and you know, great support from Paramount
and Nickelodeon and it
just feels really good.
We did the parade.
- [Kelly] I know!
I gonna ask you about that.
- [Kenan] Riding in
the Good Burger mobile.
- [Kelly] Did you like doing that?
'Cause I've done the parade
before and it's cold.
- [Kenan] It is cold.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kenan] But it was incredible.
It's so much love.
And you forget,
New York is full of
buildings that, you know,
are very tall and there's
people in the windows
like all the way up.
So like riding for a
mile through the middle
of the city with people
just waving and smiling.
It was incredible.
Like, yeah, that was us out there.
And shout out to those mechanics
'cause they got that car
to work the whole time.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] It always like, it looks good,
but like, will it run?
- [Kenan] Yeah, it is an older car.
So yeah.
They did a good job.
- [Kelly] What was like your favorite,
I asked Kel this,
what was your favorite burger place?
Like as a kid or even
now, what's your favorite?
- [Kenan] Growing up,
I feel like I was big on McDonald's.
(audience laughs)
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
My son is addicted.
- [Kenan] Yeah.
And then I went to LA and tried In & Out
and that was good.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kenan] But I don't
eat red meat anymore,
so we tried Hart House recently
and that was really good.
Kevin Hart's spot.
- [Kelly] I don't know,
I didn't eat red meat for like one year
and it was the saddest year of my life.
(audience laughs)
- [Kenan] Yeah.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kenan] It's a dearly departed friend.
- [Kenan] And you know,
I look at my friends
kind of like the little kid looking
from the window that can't go outside.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
(audience laughs)
That's like when I see my friends
having a milkshake.
'Cause I'm lactose intolerant
and I'm just like, just
tell me can I smell it?
- [Kenan] That's tough.
There's no alternative?
- [Kelly] I mean, there is.
Is it as good?
No.
- [Kenan] So why even go there?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- [Kenan] I feel you.
- [Kelly] Get out here.
- [Kelly] Yeah, I tried
like lactose free eggnog
this like holiday season.
- [Kenan] Like why?
- [Kelly] Get outta here.
- [Kenan] Nobody wants just nog.
- [Kelly] Yeah, there's no segue there.